uh first of all there is a lot of
concern about new variants
uh how does today's new vaccines
partnership how will that help with that
well this big new vaccines partnership
with curvac
is all about making sure that we use the
uk's world-leading science and genomics
capability
and we make sure that we have vaccines
that can be manufactured right here in
the uk
that can be turned around faster than
the current
generation and that can be used to
vaccinate against
any variants that might come in the
future it's all about making sure that
the uk
is as prepared as possible for whatever
might be thrown at us
lots of people have been talking about
stopping uvarians coming into the
country quarantining hotels coming in on
the 15th of february
but as lots of people point out you
don't know which country those variants
are going to come from
should we go further and expand that
list to more countries around the world
well we'll be vigilant in making sure
that the
hotel quarantine that we're introducing
applies to the right
countries where we see these new
variants
and we have a program to to have
surveillance right across the world
working with international partners to
make sure we can spot where these new
variants
pop up like brazil and south africa that
we've seen so far
and make sure that we can keep people
here safe with the new hotel quarantine
and then when it comes to the vaccine
program what are your plans for the next
stage if you like we know the 15th of
february target
looking very likely going to hit that
what about that next group all the over
50s
well we the vaccines program is going
incredibly well and it's so wonderful to
see all the pictures of people who are
being
being vaccinated and we're on track to
meet the commitment
on the 15th of february my plan is that
we should be able to offer
a vaccine to everybody in categories one
to nine that's all the over 50s by
may a lot lots of things have got to
go right to hit that goal especially
supply which is the rate limiting factor
but i'm sure that working
with the nhs and everybody else who's
making this happen
that if we can keep going at the pace we
can then we can make sure all the over
50s
get the offer of a vaccine by may and
you know what that will immediately lead
to
questions about what those people will
then be allowed to do there's lots of
talk about vaccine passports for
foreign travel for example if other
countries demand that
will the uk provide it well at the
moment
we have no plans for vaccine passports
and
anyway going on holiday is illegal in
this
lockdown of course we're constantly
working with other countries and we keep
these sorts of things under review
but for now there are still 31
670 people in hospital
with covid right now so it's imperative
that even with the good news on the
vaccine
and even with the cases starting to fall
it's imperative that everybody follows
the rules
and stay at home unless you absolutely
have to leave
because i know there's good news out
there but
we have still have very serious problems
that we've got to get through and just
finally on that
there are lots of people watching this
and some of your own mp saying
we're all looking at the graphs we can
see the good news
can you tell us more about come march
alongside schools what else might be
able to happen well it's still too early
to say that
and the reason is that even though the
vaccine program is going great guns and
you know almost 11 million people now
have been vaccinated
um it's still too early to say and 31
670 people in hospital with covid
right as we speak right now that is far
far
too many so the nhs is still under
pressure
and we've all got to do our bit to keep
those case rates going down